hey yo
[Applause]
yo hey
hey
intense body camera video shows what led
up to a deadly shooting in New Jersey
after the suspect allegedly threatened a
woman with the kitchen knife
[Applause]
on July 29th Union County New Jersey
dispatch received a 9-1-1 call from a
woman reporting an intoxicated man was
at her door
[Music]
in the 9-1-1 recording the woman can be
heard repeating that the man is drunk
she confirms her location in Elizabeth
New Jersey just south of Newark
I don't know he's drunk
okay
and uh it's Amity Amity street right yes
okay body camera video then shows
Elizabeth police officers arrive at the
scene just minutes after that 9-1-1 call
out here
unless there's him in here
which store I guess
[Applause]
video shows these same moments from
another officer's perspective
in there
as the officers approached the home
screaming can be heard coming from
behind the door that's when an officer
opens the front door and walks inside
please foreign
[Applause]
video shows the officers walk toward the
screaming according to a release by the
New Jersey Office of the Attorney
General First Responders found
42-year-old Esteban Alegria Hurtado with
a kitchen knife in his hands
see
you
[Applause]
video shows multiple other men holding
back Alegria Hurtado is the woman
screams after that body camera video
shows one of the officers approach him
seconds later its officer Stephen lasso
that opens fire
a separate recording shows these same
moments from another officer's
perspective
no
hey hey
[Applause]
after the shooting a woman can be heard
screaming saying Alegria Hurtado tried
to kill her at the same time officers
search for the knife
where's the knife
after the shooting Alegria Hurtado was
taken to the hospital he was pronounced
dead the following day the shooting
itself is now under investigation by the
State's Office of the Attorney General a
grand jury will later decide whether
charges are filed reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie